so the book that I almost wrote would
have been called Step change and the
reason why is that we are socialized or
taught to believe or believe for
whatever reason that we should always
consider incrementalism first well and
before I can open the big lemonade
business I first have to have the
lemonade stand we never consider why
can't I just go all the way to the top
there isn't a single time I innovate or
ideate for business I always call it
let's shoot for the moon and if it
doesn't go great we're gonna end up at
the top of the mountain which is a hell
of a lot better than being on the top of
this house it's the only way I can think
all right Vader Nation one of the most
exciting podcasts that I could possibly
put out because of a couple reasons one
Matt Higgins is a cult-like figure in
the Vayner world because he's been a
backer of me for a long time used to be
the president of the Jets you just
search Matt Higgins Gary vaynerchuk
there's plenty of content if you want to
go that path or I'm sure after this
we'll go that path Matt individually
outside of the connection point that we
have where Matt and Steve Ross are our
partners in the vaynerx world and now
Vayner watts and things of that nature
Matt himself has gotten a lot of heat
because he's one of the few humans who's
ever been a shark on Shark Tank and he's
done that world but I've known Matt for
a very long time and this project that
he's on now his new book
um I a because I went through that
journey and we have similarities we have
differences but I know that part but I
also know the tireless efforts and work
ethic and passion and giving a [__] and
he's a little more meticulous than I am
so probably every word on this page and
the I know the cover Journey like this
man put more effort into this cover than
I put into vaynermedia like and so I
think this should be a great interview
for a lot of reasons most of all because
I love them so that my subconscious
energy is going to deliver two I know
that this audience buys books like crazy
which is why all sorts of fancy people
who otherwise wouldn't want to talk to
me are always asking to be on the
podcast because the numbers don't lie
and all the pr people know that so I'm
excited about that because that means a
lot of people are about to
um get this book and check it out and
honestly you know I always say this the
books that I always co-sign I've never
read because I can't read books I don't
have that capacity or capability can you
make this the inaugural book nope okay
cool am I going to want to be the only
time I can is when I go on like vacation
and like but but I always go by the
person do I believe in the person and do
I think the person mailed it in because
they just want it or they went there I
know you went there and so it's really
nice to have you on the show well thank
you amazing and by the way I know you
won't because when I said do you want to
see the expert about yourself you said
no yes
I was like but I'm writing some like
intimate stuff you're like no I'm cool
yeah Matt tell everybody what the book's
about okay let's go over there first
yeah so so it's most simple version It's
all about why do we hesitate
um I've been obsessed with this topic
generally I've dealt with anxiety and
all the issues that people have been
listening to have dealt with but when I
went on the set of Shark Tank and here I
am a grown man right and you know
arguably deserve to be there and right
before I went on the night before I had
a complete meltdown really freaked out
like I didn't even know that oh yeah
yeah I like well you know I'd rather let
the tape do the talking but the reality
is the tape doesn't reflect what really
happened that imposter syndrome you
weren't sure how you would pop on TV you
didn't want it you didn't want to be
like bad at it well it was like one of
those moments like why am I bothering
first of all it's really uncomfortable
it's full of risk you can underperform
of course of course these things didn't
really materialize right we tend to
amplify these risks of course but the
night before I'd been up for two days
I'm in the hotel room and my wife Sarah
you know it's five in the morning she's
like you know okay baby are you ready to
do it I was like I haven't slipped wow
it got so bad that I said honey I have
an idea I'm going to tell them I had bad
salmon in the hotel Rohan oza is lives
nearby I'm gonna call Rohan and get him
to film I really thought that I really
thought that you know embarrassing to
admit it but she's like take a shower
pull yourself together I went in the
shower listen because I actually want
this podcast to bring a ton of value
yeah and I think I'm gonna go somewhere
that I think has a chance to really
bring back by the way I wasn't sure I
was gonna break this up no no I'm like
should I mention that but go ahead
you were a real business person in a big
organization with lots of things going
on was it more about what it was going
to do to your real life business than
you were going to be like not good on TV
it was all of that it was a mix it was
it was the haters that were going to
receive it pretty negatively yeah like
what are you doing right it was the
pressure to perform well on that one
let's break that one down because I
think that's going to help a lot of
people as well that listen to this was
it people like in your not like your
Direct business friends but those tier 2
tier 3 or was it the masses who you know
you were less known than maybe some of
the other people and was it more about
the masses saying like why this guy out
of anybody or was it like that tier two
tier three tier four circle of people
that you interact in business with like
two times a year six times a year on a
deal saying like why you not me kind of
thing exactly yeah it was not the masses
I could care less
I love that I'd rather be underestimated
it was about the ones who might have
direct effect in the outer orbit who
would say who are yeah inherently
resentful right so it was so it's like
it was all that also why are you taking
your eye off the ball what are you doing
here right right also you're a kid from
Queens you know and you you know you
have improved yourself all this all this
kind of stuff so but interestingly
enough I'm in the shower and I'm having
this reflective moment and for those who
don't know I dropped out of high school
and I was 16 and and I ended up becoming
the mayor's press secretary by the time
I was 20. so I've done this on the
podcast
really like because I want to stay
within the book lean and narrow because
as we have it on wax so please after
this Google Map Higgins Gary vaynerchuk
you'll find you'll find plenty of videos
with us but like I had this moment
saying you've been through all this to
get to this point now you're gonna
succumb when you're at the precipice
right trans so actually I owe a debt of
gratitude to the great poet Eminem
because I decided that I was gonna put
Lose Yourself on a loop for two hours
and I do I have a video of me in the car
I didn't take it off the entire time
until the cameras got rolling I would
say hello hey Damon you know and I kept
it on a loop because I was like that guy
exactly and then uh I had a moment in
the middle of our taping totally froze
and Mark Cuban you know leaned over to
me and you could tell it was kind of
look a Pity like who invited this guy
and um it all clicked like wait a second
I was like I've done as many deals as
anybody here I've done all this kind of
stuff right and then that that little
conversation in my head I do a complete
180. I talk about this in a book when
it's done Gary you could appreciate this
I compete for the first deal against you
you've been at O'Leary yep I win that
deal yep and Laura ganier turns to me
and she said Matt in the history of
Shark Tank no one has come on and walked
on the set like they were there from the
first day that's awesome and when I tell
this story because everybody out there
if you saw the tape you'd say oh he's a
natural I'm not a natural I want you to
know I'm not a natural and you don't
need to be a natural but you do need to
overcome that voice in your head that
makes sense and that's what the book is
about and and what else is the book
about like for a cool makes sense I
actually love the way you act I I love
the concept of hesitation
um because that is you selling yourself
in the other direction what how'd you
what about the title so the title so uh
burn the boats um
from the beginning of recorded history
anytime you have a military leader and
they are outnumbered you know ten to one
and they need to do the impossible they
always use the same language different
same Concepts in different languages
right of this idea that um to get the
most out of you you need to eliminate
your Escape Route and also eliminate
your food so it's in the Art of War it
says burn the boats and the cooking pots
it goes back to the ancient Israelites
it goes back to Caesar Crossing the
Rubicon it goes back to a very bad man
Cortez but he used the same the same
concept usually attributed to him this
notion that humans perform best when
they have no plan B you've heard this
before but a lot of people don't believe
it when I wanted this statement to be
provocative so that 25 of the audience
would say yeah that's easy to say but I
have malice to feed or or I have bills
that's all it is right right I mean so I
would argue that the dominant framework
of my content that I put into the world
only is responded with stuff like that
exactly easy for you or this and that
100 right there's a framework of excuse
and I always say to the people I most
care about if we go into a deeper
conversation about it is if anyone has
ever done it in your circumstance then
this argument is over if anyone with an
alcoholic father has ever succeeded in
happiness and business success well then
this argument is over I love that you
say that because I one of the problems
you could relate to this now I'm
perceived as a guy on Shark Tank I
perceived at the end of the journey and
at the beginning of the journey correct
this book is my attempt to rewind let me
take you back to that shoebox apartment
in Queens New York when I'm literally
eating government cheese sleeping on a
mattress taking care of my mother let me
take you to the moment that I had cancer
or that I got divorced yeah right all
these different moments that you could
say all right I don't want that also I
can relate to that sure and so the the
the point being I am the most paranoid
risk taker ever gonna you know this guy
right like
so this is like a really fun podcast
because I actually like no you know I
know and so burn the boats it's not burn
the boats with you on it it's the the
point of the book is that um you should
process Risk by all means you need to
process risk at the beginning of the
journey and say what's the worst that
could possibly happen once you've
process risk and synthesized it then you
can go forth fearlessly it's fine so my
paranoia as you know is front loaded yes
right yes but then I go yeah I like that
when don't you go I was actually going
to just jump in that you're right it's
all the upfront and then you know once
the ink is signed well then right we're
going but I notice and this is not how
you roll that a lot of people get joy
uh in filling the void or it's their way
where they aren't good at that that even
after the deal you shook on it you
signed it you started it you opened the
store that they they go into dwell City
quickly often a month later we shouldn't
have done this and all the energy goes
into we shouldn't have done this because
it was a bad 30 days instead of all that
energy you need to make the next 30 days
awesome is that touched on what do you
think about that that is more the point
of the book that that actually what I'm
trying to demonstrate and there's a lot
of Academia in the book to prove the
point that the mere contemplation of a
plan b or whatever or your Escape Route
dramatically reduces reduces the
probability you'll be successful so
there's an incredible story out of
Wharton not to get all uh you know but
from 2014 where they wanted to prove
that that uh you know that that idea and
they had you know two groups of you know
students going ahead and undertaking and
exercise and all they had to do was
think about another way to achieve of
the result and they were able to
demonstrate a material reduction in not
only the likelihood that they would
achieve it but the desire to actually
achieve it so that's why military think
of it makes sense you're about to die
and they harness this idea that you have
no Escape Route so the boat the reason
because if you can run away from dying
that seems
the only way to do it is to kill
everyone right so so the boats in my
case is not really your Escape Route
it's the things that recur in your life
internally and externally that make you
revisit whether you should have did you
you know it's funny did you you know one
thing my publisher struggles with with
me
is I want to make books that aren't
timeless
yeah like my one of my favorite books is
jab jab jab right hook it was the
current state of social media content
that worked then I'm literally the next
book I'm going to write is jab jab jab
left hook because I want to update it
because green screen Tick Tock green
screen and Tick Tock didn't exist when I
wrote that and they always make fun of
me and I always say look Crusher did so
well because it's more Universal and
like I remember when you were telling me
about this book I'm like ooh this is
such a universal like this is a book
that can like did you give that thought
I also a lot of people who listen to
this are more advanced in their careers
and think about writing the book did
that even hit your radar is this just a
book you want to write or were you
conscious that like oh if this does well
it's doing well 13 years from now
because it's a universal message no this
is this is my attempt to engineer an
outcome to write something that endures
there's no question yeah because I
believe in this so so that was the
starting point and then you kind of you
have 13 15 things just like don't
hesitate that you thought through and
out of all the things that you think are
Universal this is what you zeroed in on
and this is the was there something that
was a close second oh that's a great
question here's a fun question yeah
there was
so the book that I almost wrote would
have been called Step change step change
and it would have and the reason why is
that we are socialized or taught to
believe or believe for whatever reason
that we should always consider
incrementalism first well and before I
can open the big lemonade business I
first have to have the lemonade stand
and that is a very corrupting thought we
never consider why can't I just go all
the way to the top so but my bias and
your bias is that's how I ended up at
Harvard Business School I could have
taught at Queen's College I love
everyone at Queen's college but I said
why can't I be the best what would it
take to be the best by the way to your
point there isn't a single time I
innovate or ideate for business where I
don't I always call it and you've heard
this a million times listen let's shoot
for the moon and if it doesn't go great
we're gonna end up at the top of the
mountain which is a hell of a lot better
than being on the top of this house
right it's the only way I can think
right and I I one of the best and I'm
gonna talk about it I'm gonna write a
new book called Step change right he was
doing together
what let's go back to this real quick
what else will people get out of it what
do you what's your gut tell you end or I
love tell us an anecdotal story from
somebody who's already read it in your
inner circles that isn't like someone
who blindly is going to say this is
remarkable because they love you so much
and actually gave you an insight to what
they consumed so what you got to pick on
my vulnerability that is my paranoia
though people are telling me they like
it or people know me
so so what do you what are you gonna get
um You probably feel the same way too A
lot of the business books some of them
are great I love atomic habits some of
the few other ones yeah but I'd say the
majority tend to be really redundant and
they tend to be written as if they're
reference books like they're a textbook
yes and people are going to refer to
them yes that the reason why we keep
buying the same book over and over again
is because it doesn't stick right I set
out to buy a book that was written like
a novel so the best compliment I've
gotten interesting even my own son you
know yeah I sat there for five hours and
read it all the way and he he turned to
me it's like it reads like truth which
was amazing that's awesome so I worked
really hard to write a very readable
book number two 2 I did case studies
that took a lot of effort there are 50
different people in this book from
billionaires to NFL coaches to my
partner Scarlett Johansson like all
talking about the moment that they had
to cross you know that barrier and fully
commit to their full potential the
number one thing you'll get out of this
book is a feeling information great is
the feeling that [__] I can do yeah I
love that that emotion and so so far I
was let's just say out of 20 people no
joke Gary at least six different people
have come to me and said your book gave
me the conviction and confidence to make
it radical change I believe it it almost
makes me pass out like if I could no
seriously like this is my life like it's
the most important thing I've ever done
yeah I could actually scale that it
makes me like oh my God all right now
let's go into another thing that's going
to be Universal for this audience
selling it yeah I like that part too
let's talk about that okay how have you
been thinking about it how's it been
going when's the book come out but comes
out on February 14th Valentine's Day I
pretend there's a logic to that give
yourself the gift of love it's because
it's on Tuesday really irritates me yeah
but everybody pretend that there's all a
reason right yeah so um so selling it
can I tell you why in The Burning Heart
or is it is that the song I never know
words in the Burning
Heart right yeah I feel like you should
do some sort of piece of social content
on the Valentine's Day the heart burning
I feel like you should you help me with
that you should do a shirtless workout
video reading the book on Valentine's
Day morning with the Burning Heart in
the background so how's it going you're
saying yeah
um I I know I didn't think I would enjoy
it so much because it's turned me to
such bottom feeder Behavior like I've
lost all dignity and I love it because I
care so much about it and I've never had
a product to sell before isn't it crazy
we own all these companies together and
I own Magnolia Bakery but they've never
been mine right this never had to sell
right I bleed in this book like and I
put things in there that I I read I
can't even finish them sometimes right I
talk about my mother at the end and I
talk about again it's not an
autobiography so I enjoy it plus so much
engineering went into it to your point
there were over 400 iterations of that
cover like on the record I usually just
tell somebody on garyvee's design team
can you design a cover I look at them
like approved Dustin you know that to be
true right
yeah let's get sitting here watch this
but I this will just be a fun moment in
the podcast
Sid
Sid you've been around long enough what
is the normal process of how I do a
cover of a book
it's a hundreds hundreds of minutes
hundreds of iterations does he do I
think Gary sees like the second last
version of it
how quickly do I usually approve it or
make changes how long you look at it 10
seconds and how and what just usually
comes out of my mouth after those 10
seconds the longest tagline ever
and uh very little changes probably
those last Origins it sounds very
similar in my process only the opposite
400 generations of this cover yeah 411
to be honest but oh and I know it's me
by the way I know it to be true I got
involved so now I was like got wired in
on a text and he's like I need you
immediately and I was like what is it
he's like that's totally true
what do you think of this I'm like I
don't [__] I actually put more effort
into Matt's cover than I did in all six
of my [__] books that is actually
true thank you said go back to work okay
can I tell you why yeah four out of five
business books are actually still bought
at retail so I looked at this as as
bottom of the funnel again right so but
real quick on that point the boat the
boats generally is a metaphor for
whatever it is holding you back right
and a big premise of the book is uh the
first thing that you start with the fish
rots from the head what are you carrying
around that you haven't dealt with that
can make you lighter and the first thing
is to shed your shame so the image on
the book looks kind of like a like a
like a paper boat floating in a bathtub
and that represents all the things from
childhood that tend to hold it I like
that and so I talk a lot about my
journey to overcome losing my mother and
again it's not an autobiography the part
I love about the book Grant front cover
quote that's a good one
let's talk about engineering yeah so the
back of the covers the quotes on the
back is this is a mock yeah uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger yep uh David Solomon so
you have Goldman Sachs Jay shetting all
right uh Bobby Brown uh Mark Cuban you
know so I worked huge a couple months
because most people only have
endorsements within their vertical and I
thought like this I meant this book is
meant to appeal to the masses so maybe
it was a little extra around the cover I
admit that
no it's pretty cool and what about the
selling what do you think what did what
what have you learned that people can
you know take from the selling process
what was harder what was easier and
obviously it still hasn't come out
because of this recording when do you
want me to put this out uh after
February 14th I mean you know the
pre-sales count towards the first week
sales I know you agreeing to agree but
but if you look at business books and
people I want I want all the Impressions
to hit when people can see it at a
bookstore okay subscribe so we'll put it
out we'll put it out do you want me to
put out of the morning of yeah that
would be amazing got it but but in terms
of what people would take away too I try
to articulate a lot of abstract Concepts
that we all deal with it but haven't
been able to put your finger on so for
example I'll go through the archetypes
of bad leaders one of them is this idea
of a withholder that I'm obsessed with
that person in your life whether they're
a manager who refuses to give you praise
because they know you feed on it because
they they know you're a person who seeks
approval and they and they use it to
destabilize your self-esteem interesting
and so what's great when you write your
own book you can give an aims to things
that don't exist like you're in
sociology in college right I got to name
things but a lot of things that hold us
back these external obstacles that I
think I do a really good job and then I
use these different case studies to
illustrate those and what about that
that little scenario because I like that
like is the book telling people that
they should work on themselves so they
don't need validation from others or is
it
selling them look out for these people
while you're in the process of getting
stronger well look there's no new ideas
in the universe right so all I'm trying
to do is hold up a mirror and validate
that you know what what you suspect
you're feeling is true you're a partner
your wife or your husband is withholding
deliberately your bosses and two to the
per people in power this especially
applies to artists artists tends to be
the ones who are unable to advocate for
themselves especially financially yes
and it tends to be the ones who can be
destabilized by that treatment I think
when you're dealing with somebody with
Artistry you have an obligation to be
their Advocate that's nice so it's a
message to management but I go through
these five different archetypes the part
I'm most I'm proudest of in the book is
taking these case studies where people
have allowed me to share their very
vulnerable raw stories and I'd love to
talk about one please we got a minute
please
um there's my partner Aiden Kehoe yeah
and we uh we have a cyber security
business together I acquired his
business you know Aiden right Irishman
from you know he's a bartender yeah he
ends up in all these improbable jobs
insurance broker then ends up creating a
cyber security the company we acquired
his company and very quickly I realized
that um Aiden because got a big heart
and was carrying a lot of trauma would
not deal with conflict with employees
and so he was not upgrading his staff
and as soon as we took an outside
Capital we would have these
conversations saying like Aidan man like
you got to make a move here you gotta
make a move there they're going to eat
you alive right so it started
accumulating there's always compounds
right same way money compounds problems
compound right so over time started
taking a lot of incoming at the same
time very difficult home situation A
Child on the Spectrum just coming from
every direction right I get a phone call
one night from him and he's uh crying
through the you know through the phone
basically saying hey Matt
like I failed you I am so sorry like I'm
out I'm gonna resign I don't know if you
know the story no I don't three years in
I'm gonna resign uh end of the year and
I said first of all what's that noise in
the background I hear beeping
and he's like uh I'm in the hospital my
daughter is getting tested for seizures
uh you know just everything's falling
apart and I was like first of all Aiden
I'm perfectly comfortable calling you
when it's over I was like it's not over
it's just beginning you're at the moment
of capitulation I was like you need to
hang up the phone you need to take care
of your child right now and you call me
when you're ready to do the work
you know a few days later he calls me
like you could hear it in his voice he
had contemplated the worst case scenario
total failure company didn't work and
had let it go yeah and the real work
began I'll skip some of the most
important details but he started working
with an industrial psychologist that you
know me love those industrial psychology
I love that [__] so Matt hasn't met an
outside consultant that's not true
psychologists but but actually this is a
strength of yours this is a weakness of
mine you know me I'm like the reverse no
you're right you're like get away from
my head get out of my head I'm in my
cocoon yeah I can barely speak to AJ and
you or anybody thank God I don't hold
you accountable for anything I would be
dead how does your partnership work it's
like I don't have a boat
so so but listen how amazing it is you
know it's funny I think a lot about
Investors and I think about value add
yeah right and I do think that one of
the strengths you have is take you as
you come well that for damn with me for
damn sure I can't speak how you've met
like no you you know it's all different
you're just like but it's also like
people always ask me like family
business questions they're like how do I
get my dad you got your debt your dad I
was like cool my dad who I give my dad
Sasha the most credit he gave me tons of
room but it came because he watched when
I was 15 when you're [__] 15 years
old and you look nine
and your father says to you there's 50
cases of this thing over here that's not
selling and then he's downstairs like he
ran the business from his office he did
us all his meetings and he comes
upstairs at like four hours later to
check on the floor and like 11 of the
cases are gone you're gonna start
building confidence you know what I
think you do well is you watch you know
you invested what year did you you and
Steve invest in my feelings 2015. right
right so like you guys like in the you
watched and very quickly you're like
okay good like this guy can do it and
you took your energy it's what I do with
mine actually I do that I think it gives
me too much credit because there were
moments when I would also like question
hey Gary why aren't you talking about
yourself as a business person I want to
give you that little speech you're
always you know you're not you're under
representing just what a business yeah
you're always nice about it like that's
interesting Matt yeah I'll do more
LinkedIn posts you don't know what the
[__] you're talking about but uh it's
great so but I think you know I really
do think of value add and I do think you
as an investor do what I do as an OP
operator which is you you play every
scenario different you know that's so
many of your Investments Through The
Years randomly sometimes that like
things that we're together at and other
times just like at an airport and you
know like my experience is different
than other people's and I always laugh I
never say it to them but we're kind of
going transparent here on the thing
they're like hey you know like Matt is
you know like checks in a lot I mean
like you know like that's right and my
brain goes to you need it I know that's
like where my brain went to because I
know that you do that with me thus it by
the way it's the same thing I do in my
company now with divisions and offices
and there's eight or nine vaynerx
companies and then there's the Boehner
things that are outside Watt and sports
like you know like I only you know when
you're at the levels that we're playing
at you're putting your finger in the
holes that have the ish back to boats
right right
Buckley I'll give her some roses if
she's crushing in La I like I don't know
I don't need to necessarily like look at
it I don't have to put my finger in in
there also you don't want to because
you're not self-aggrandizing right I
think you do well that I'm trying to do
better is
I go so macro that I'm like it's all
good but if you can help it better and
in this scenario it was a it was
something that wasn't working as well
but like you're very good at bringing
outside energy it's not just Capital
it's like and it's not just like you you
tend to match people up yeah it's a
strength of yours and that's what you
did in that stuff and I wonder if that
ties back to this book which is like if
you're hesitating
what energy like it makes sense that you
can't figure it out yourself well not
only that
um lean on something or someone
self-awareness is the greatest single
Arbitrage professionally and personally
it's entirely within your control 100 so
in a situation like that and I do do
this well I create space for somebody to
eliminate their excuse because I'm
sharing all these details right like
you're okay let me just tell you the
Eden story I'm sorry okay no I was just
summarized I was excited about now the
bottom line is he does all this
incredible self work and he goes through
this process with the industrial
psychologist and it's a very
uncomfortable process because somebody's
holding up a mirror to you and they also
have a PhD so they're not there were 95
accurate and there are things you
thought you were concealing he gets the
report right you know detailing all his
issues and we're in this meeting and um
he said excuse me for a second he walks
out of the room goes into the room next
to it he's at a staff meeting he said
here read this report you can pass it
all around because you already know
everything about me and I have a lot of
work to do he made a single decision he
was no longer going to work on
concealing he was going to do a 180 and
create a culture of total transparency
in in probably about 19 months turn the
whole business around and had a massive
nine-figure exit what could have been a
zero and so to me I I to me that story
illustrates the power of self-awareness
if you just choose to look within and
again the whole book is not about that
obviously but it starts there as as you
know
um but anyway that's the what else do
you want people to know about this book
or a story in it or anything like I want
to go a little more meat and potatoes if
there's anything yeah no I I I I I what
I want you to know is that it would
probably be pretty hard for you to look
through this book and not seem some see
some reflection of what you're going
through right now or somebody that you
admire particularly
um I worked really hard to profile women
entrepreneurs because my background has
been populated by strong women of course
you know obviously my mother but but but
all the mentors I've had in my life my
wife has unlocked my entire success and
so so the first entrepreneur you
encounter in this book is a woman and
the last one you encountered in this
book and so I'm really proud of the way
and again not in a in a lecture way yeah
no Warren is celebrating like the truth
it's the truth isn't it funny it's such
a weird talk about dni or this I'm like
it's just the reality remember early in
the podcast I'm like if anyone looks
like you and your situation and mate
like there's unlimited stories of people
that are not white men that have built
iconic business like it's silly it's
silly talk yeah it's silly talk Matt to
to make this very contextual to this
audience using me as a proxy and will
help people when you when you because
how many Investments have you and Steve
done together oh I I don't even know I
know but like we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars yeah
yeah but hundreds right yeah yeah okay
so think about this everyone I want you
to hear this let's use me and then I'm
gonna use maybe one or two other of your
entrepreneurs because I think this may
help maybe using the framework of the
book maybe not because it's a general
podcast
we've established that everybody needs
to buy a ton of books uh please
um
if I wasn't me and I'm doing this
podcast and I said I want you to analyze
the entrepreneurs that you've backed
what is what is different about Gary
vaynerchuk's operation style that you
think is different than what you see
across your Investments and what's
common then we're going to play this
game with other people besides me but I
want to make it fun with my audience if
somebody said to you like what is the
biggest single thing or things
that Gary operates in what currency
Styles things like what what stands out
that's super different because I think
if when we do this with a couple others
it may give some people some themes to
lean into their differences because I
think leaning into the things that make
you unique are actually places of
confidence to not hedge I agree so this
is all right so what do you think I do
forget I do plenty of things well and
not well like other entrepreneurs and
some of those things that I do well are
similar to Jesse and others that you've
invested in but what do you think is
uniquely different about how I do things
from what you've seen because you've
seen a [__] a lot yeah let me tell
you what popped into my head immediately
two words structural Integrity you are
constructed with perfect Integrity
because you are authentic and everything
about you is there's nothing in Conflict
inside of yourself you sleep eight hours
you you have your things that you you
put out you you you have no shame
because you have nothing to hide yep and
as a result you're able to move
effortlessly
right I was like I wish I could be so
self-possessed like and I don't know
anyone else who possesses that uh in the
Empire including myself so that's the
number and I think it's a big reason for
your success we have this conversation
all the time like Gary does this stress
you out you're like nope I asked you so
the other day you're like you know he
said to me I love it and I talked to my
wife about this and sometimes talking to
me is like taking a warm bath like Epsom
salt I was neurotic about something as I
often am and and you said Matt no
because I'm a good person and I was like
yeah I can't argue with that and so
structural Integrity when you have that
you're able to move in in One Direction
let's go into your portfolio because
you're gonna know better than I do give
me than another person that you can
bring up tell us their business and tell
them tell us what makes her or him
their unique thing that's different than
the rest oh I love that
um Christina Tosi yes um Christina
Christina Tosi when you interact with
her you can give everybody oh sorry guys
everyone out there Christina Tosi is the
founder of Milk bar right great Great
Dessert brand an amazing human being
when you are with her you know that she
is rooting for you to be successful
there isn't an ounce of her that feels
like she wins by you by you losing so
she's an one of my favorite things she's
a big
cheering for everyone to build the
biggest building they can build has very
little energy to tearing any other
building yeah yeah nice and then again
even her competitors uh 100 and back to
the point of like understanding and I do
have a philosophy you know this you take
your Founders and you take people as
they come and you try to amplify their
positives and help them mitigate their
downsides but not and I always are you
somebody who pokes holes or plugs holes
do you poke at a hole poke at a
vulnerability or do you try to plug it
so her her skill now at the same time
she's also a really good person she's a
creative and so you at the same time
wouldn't expect her to be perfectly at
ease with conflict and you know and
situations where there's potentially you
know volatile toxic person like you got
to help somebody work through those
situations so there's I got a good one
without naming names okay and you might
not even want to go too deep into the
details because it might expose it no
I'm sure I cover I covered the
archetypes in a book so I'm sure so tell
me an example of through these years of
investing
what because I think this will be fun
for the audience what was the blind spot
for you I'll give you mine real fast I I
came out the gate hot Facebook Twitter
you know that's a lot of what we did our
fund on was how well my stuff looked
when I look back I somewhere early on
veered away from judging the operator
and judging the idea and was making
pretend I was gonna operate it and could
see it succeed if I had operated it and
at that point I didn't understand how
much better of an operator I was than
the masses and I didn't realize how much
that was actually the variable not just
the idea was the idea was genuinely
always important but actually a 1B to
the operator because you could kill any
good idea Facebook Google Uber all could
have died if the operator wasn't right
and did die before those things they
were built before no new ideas
Friendster is Facebook like you know
like so
um what was yours if you look back at
your first half decade or even right now
what's the cliche thing that gets you
[__] up but it's like you'll make a
bet and you're like [__] that same theme
or you probably plugged it at this point
because you've been deploying Capital
real capital for a long time but what
was it I was going to use yours I won't
use yours because is it the same it is
number one so I'll give you number two
by the way everyone should take note of
that yeah that it's a cliche it's always
it's always the jockey we tend to reject
the cliches because we want to break new
ground there is no no ground or no
ground to break we've been around
somebody at home that's not a investor
this is true in hiring too yeah for
everybody who's hiring someone you you
can you know what they would like you
know what they should do and you just
like the person you haven't figured out
if they're capable of doing it right so
bring that into you possibly by the way
when you do a search and you land on
your number one and if you can't get
your number one you should abandon the
whole search and start over again
because those are the there's a reason
you didn't like your numbers exactly the
best decisions are relative decisions
but I'm gonna do my number two since you
took number one number one is you know
it is about the jockey it's a damn
cliche it's 100 too and a and a week um
a weak jockey will never be able to even
if they have a great idea right but the
flip side is true a great jockey can
Eclipse a bad idea because they'll
iterate through it but number two is
um and I've totally done a pivot on this
opportunity cost is now my first thought
I always say when I write this check I'm
not investing I'm getting a new job yeah
and I have to ask myself three years to
five years from now can all this will
this be working can I give you a real
one yeah outside of our Network you know
because we had a fun then we had a gap
and then we had a fund
I did a personal investment this weird
up the other day
personal investment wrote a fairly big
check for me and my personal investment
realm team comes to me Phil included and
says hey you own 17 of this company and
the company's like about to die but your
personal brand can actually help it
again
and I said no
I said I don't I don't want to run the
business I have you know how many
businesses I run right I didn't sign up
for a rescue mission right so like
that's where you know like and I'm in a
unique spot on top of everything else
because I have a platform that can bring
awareness and so yeah you can change it
yeah and like but like but then what am
I doing like like you know like not that
I want that investment because the
opportunity costs are a problem but also
knowing so let's take that one step
further opportunity cost is a problem
for anyone which we don't focus enough
on but it's really a problem for
somebody who acts like the Marines they
leave no man or woman behind because
that means that when you're confronted
with a situation like you and I are yeah
I refuse to let things die so now I pay
an even double tax because so now I
forecast future Behavior at least try to
do better and say one who am I going to
care about in three years and two am I
gonna die trying to save it because I
know some of your trials and
tribulations that makes that's a good
one yeah opportunity cost is real as
[__] what's your number three
to you know I don't tend to play too
early I think the nft stuff was like
that we just did a lot of investing in I
knew that it was web 9697 I think I
think trying to figure out which ones
are going to make it through this like
right now I'm enjoying the V friends
thing I don't know if I've enjoyed
something more than what is the meetings
I'm having about the event annoys me
with this whole thing is I wish you had
just told me like Matt do crypto punks
instead you had me do millions of
dollars
by the way he's being a dick everyone
why'd you let me do all these stupid
like I can't control you that's fair
you're a maniac
by the way hey do you know how enjoyable
it is every 24 or 36 months or so well
this is
only just wants to get a text from you
can you call
you call he's like you were right again
like because I like to hold myself
accountable you give me roses right
right and I'm you know this about me Ma
I tend not to be wrong because I'm
petrified of it yeah you're right yeah
it's funny people always say like oh
Gary is like kind of like a gunslinger I
was like are you kidding he's way more
risk adverse than I am you're not
paranoid but you also are more measured
actually I really am I'm loud and
chaotic as a communicator but to your
point you know the truth people would be
stunned yeah if they looked at the math
they would think it'd be reversed I'm
the guy with the jacket on you know but
you're the one who takes so much you
know because it's like I just don't want
to be wrong you really don't I really
don't yeah you're more way more
competitive than I am you actually are
way more competitive I'm actually I'm
actually lost to my head and I'm
actually not competitive with the
outside world no you're playing with me
I'm playing with my thoughts so
um we got a few minutes without what did
we touch on oh actually we didn't talk
about this okay
um did you end up doing the packages
I did end up doing the so so everybody
everybody as many of you know because
you've done this
through the years I've had a lot of
success in like if you buy 100 books of
this you get
you get books of my book you get that
because I always want my books to do
well I want to get them out there when
Matt called me he's like hey you've been
fairly successful in this genre like
what's the story I'm like hey I really
think the packages especially you
because I know so many people I get
emails hey can I pitch mad a business
for 15 minutes I'm like you might be
able to do like a buy 50 books and get
to pitch a shark like it felt very real
to me so did you end up getting to do
packages or you did not do so yes and no
okay I I followed your advice which was
brilliant which was create the packages
and they're amazing right and they're
like they're wallpaper and eye candy I I
didn't find anything to try to push them
because the difference is it still real
uh it exists but well we could do it
right now
I would say I would say the most go to
oh burn the boatsbook.com and you'll be
able to find packages
packages
so let's go to that burnthebooks.com
burn the boats books the boats book.com
right
what is what are the packages do you
remember I would say the ones that are
are most useful or interesting or pitch
a shark because everyone always wants to
go how many books was that time I can't
remember okay should I pull it up 50
books
so so um that one I think is you know
you did do it I did do it and my
thinking was even if uh I didn't work
hard to push those packages I love
checking every box as you know right
yeah I don't want to look back and say I
didn't burn the boats and run every
tactic but I to be honest Gary I enjoyed
the act of going to my relationships and
saying I've put 47 years of my heart and
soul into this like please please buy it
because I've never is it under bonuses
um yes okay here we go here's what you
ended up doing five books invite the VIP
burn the books webinar um to the
audience Gary's about to find out that
one of those packages involves Gary yeah
I see my picture and I'm like
I'm in it hey Gary can you do a package
you're doing it like a whole course
don't worry about it please stop
so I am I'm in it 25 bucks join Matt and
Christina Tosi for a virtual baking
tutorial very good right pretty cool
very cheap yeah
for her yeah so go back to go to the
dolphins go to the Dolphins it's a shark
live one-on-one Zoom with Matt yeah
that's probably the most valuable right
that's gonna get the most yeah that's
what's gonna happen here just yeah
because that's really obviously very
real 150 take take your team through a
business case live with Magnolia very
interesting so like that's Consulting
around 150 cheap
500 books the ultimate NFL experience
join Matt and the piece of [__]
Miami Dolphins in Miami
want to live out your foot but Matt will
host up to four guests in a once in a
lifetime talion in the 72 Club
field passes or
dolphin fans definitely definitely check
this out because I know what the cost on
it
day of deep sea fishing with Matt
because you know how much 500 bucks I do
right Gary and I never got fishing
outside the Statue of Liberty remember
that Matt's Big Apple 1 000 books join
Matt for an afternoon evening Adventure
in New York starting with a helicopter
ride I was going to build that to you by
the way wait I'm in this too yeah yeah
well the Hudson yards for me with well
it's our helicopter
yeah basically my my Pat my strategy is
just to take you you literally they
leverage you yeah yeah you took it very
little but I was gonna wait till it
works packages like me not put me in the
but then once they were successful then
I would ask you to do it burning the
boats I am dying right now well everyone
check out burnthebodesbook.com I think
pitch the shark is probably probably the
most valuable because I think in 15
minutes is all I need to change a
trajectory of your life and and I really
I feel great about I love doing it and
so that's probably the one that I'm I'm
mostly listening everybody we're gonna
wrap up like with an actual left hook
um you know one thing I do for my
friends is because I have a bunch of
employees is buy a bunch of books put
them in the hallway so anybody you know
who has got a company with 10 or 12 or
19 employees by the way I know Matt he's
a he's a sucker because I'm a sucker
because I'm in every package I'm sure if
you come up with your own package and
email them and say hey will you talk to
the whole company got 113 employees
though about about 13 bucks like he's
trickable is all I'm trying to tell you
I'm trying to give my audience value
since you took all the value out of me
there all right wait wait yes before you
go because you're here yeah and then all
my friends out there in the metaverse
will be upset if I didn't ask you you
know have gone really deep into the ens
right the naming system you're a huge I
know but you know how everyone's
bothering you on Twitter now I have to
bother you on this podcast whatever you
know we blew it I told you and AJ that
over the holidays hit me up we'll do
like two hours and we didn't do it
kidding me no instead you hit me up and
we did like an hour on the book that's
fair
so all the ens people just so you know
he sold you out for his own book did you
know that that was a misdirection I'm
really excited about the ens thing I'm
just so [__] busy back to like you
know what are we talking about I bought
for you something I bought a name for
you that I'm waiting for it for you to
receive I I am going to make a
commitment to get educated here and
understand why everyone is as passionate
about it I'm aware that everyone
believes this big space I just have not
done my own homework you know I love to
do my own homework I will I'll have you
and AJ help me I look forward to that
we'll do that in February
please buy the book everyone burn the
boatsbook.com is where you should all go
uh the book is actually out today
because we are we recorded this in late
January and we're publishing it on
Valentine's Day Happy Valentine's Day
Matt I love you and I love you can I
have the last word Gary you're you're
everybody asked me all this all the time
what's Gary really like Gary really is
like everything you perceive about Gary
that you are the most pure form of a
person and you take a lot of heat a lot
of questions you know there's always
haters all this [__] out there I I'm
always in awe of um just how much
Integrity you have and and I do I'd like
to I love to be around people that I can
learn from and make me think how I could
be better you are that person for me
that's very humbling thank you brother
Happy Valentine's Day
[Music]